the Science Museum group has a
collection of more than seven million
items today space curator Doug Millard
shows why one very special chair now
sits here in the collection as I
discover another story from the stores
when they said space chair this is not
exactly what I had in mind it doesn't
look like a space chair does it it looks
like a dining chair with some boxes
attached secrets this has come all the
way from Houston Texas Mission Control
this is a real chair that was used to
train astronauts on which Michener's
would have used this for training this
would have been used for for example the
Hubble Space Telescope deployment and
probably the servicing missions this
actual chair dates back to the mid
sixties so it's possible it was also
used on the Apollo program Wow it's a
very basic chair apart from what's
attached to it well the controls to my
mind are similar to sort of early video
games
buta games and in a way that's what they
do they just allow you to manipulate in
this case the remote manipulator arm of
the the shuttle to enable the
coordination between hand and eye
because that's how it was done it was
very basic operation so is that a 2010
is equivalent out there with a flat-pack
chair and a joystick from a video game
show I imagine there would be because
this remote manipulator arm is being
updated and it's used on the space
station in fact several of them so
there'd be some device equivalent to
this that the astronauts and cosmonauts
can use to actually train how to grab
things and move them along the space
station it looks almost botched together
but this is such a well massive thing
that this is it you see where sometimes
that would be witched by the spectacle
of space exploration the romance and the
seems very removed literally but
actually you've got to start by building
things like this to my mind it is this
juxtaposing of the Space Age
with an everyday looking chair it's just
gloriously evocative
you